[Music]
if time travel is possible why haven't
we met a single time traveler yet and if
we did meet one how would we know they
weren't faking it
what would their time machine look like
and how would it operate would there be
a set of rules for time travelers to
follow and what would happen if they
decided to break them this is what if
and here's what would happen if you met
a time traveler in 1998 a gentleman by
the name of John Titor
arrived from the future or so he said in
his timeline as he claimed General
Electric had managed to invent time
travel in the Year 2034 he even showed
and described his time-traveling device
in great detail and then Tito vanished
as abruptly as he appeared did he finish
his mission or was he real at all
how could we know if we were able to
prove that someone has traveled from a
different time it would be very cool for
science although it might overwrite
Albert Einstein's theory of relativity
Einstein approached time as a fourth
dimension space is a three dimensional
spectrum that provides us with length
width and height time offers direction
together they form a space-time
continuum and it can be affected by
gravity
according to Einstein's theory of
relativity gravity is a curve in
space-time and technically because space
and time are one gravity could bend time
as well as space but you'd need
something really really big to notice
any changes in the movement of time if
you somehow managed to get yourself
close to a black hole like Sagittarius a
you'd be experiencing time at half speed
compared to people on earth this is
because Sagittarius a packs a mass of
four million Suns into an indefinitely
dense point creating a very strong
gravitational field around it another
way to travel in time is to move really
fast the closer you get to the speed of
light the slower time passes for you if
you were a passenger on a train that
somehow could travel at 99% of the speed
of light for every year you spent on the
train 223 years would have passed back
at the station that would make you a
time traveler into the future but what
about traveling back in time just like
John Titor said he did Teitur claims
that this little machine is what made
time travel possible in any direction
the C 204 as he called it allowed him to
manipulate gravity with the help of two
micro singularities that were packed
inside it also had gravity sensors to
lock the machine and time traveler in a
fixed place in space Tito had this
machine installed in a car pretty much
like the good old time-traveling
DeLorean did but it would only take him
as far as 60 years from his time how
would you know that Tito was actually
traveling in time and not just making it
up proving that someone really is a time
traveler might be even harder than time
travel itself time travelers could make
predictions about the future show their
futuristic technology or even undergo
some genetic testing to support their
story maybe the best way to prove time
travel is real would be to take you with
them on their next adventure
of course there are easier ways to prove
the possibility of time travel in 2009
the world-famous theoretical physicist
Stephen Hawking threw a party not just
any party but one to which only future
time travelers were invited Hawking
didn't send off invitations until after
the party he believed that if travelers
from the future arrived before the
invitation was released that would prove
that time travel will become possible
one day he sat there waiting for hours
but nobody showed up
that doesn't mean time travel is
impossible there is a chance that time
travelers from the future will learn to
use wormholes or bridges in space-time
we haven't seen one of those yet but the
theory of general relativity predicts
that they exist the biggest problem with
wormholes is that they're microscopic
and collapse too quickly for a human
traveler to go through but maybe the
reason nobody attended Hawking's party
is that time traveling might not be that
precise maybe the guests from the future
did arrive but they were too late for
the party
or maybe going back in time is strictly
prohibited for time travelers because if
they do they might change their timeline
completely perhaps they're just trying
to avoid the risk of spreading any
diseases from the far future onto us or
maybe the information about time
traveling is so highly classified that
only a few people would be trusted with
it maybe travelling back into time isn't
possible after all maybe time can only
move forward and never backwards maybe
John Titor was one big lie we have a few
more years until 2034 to find out in a
way we already have time travelers in
our lifetime astronauts on the
International Space Station are moving
at eight kilometers per second
this makes them age slower although the
difference is measured in hundreds of a
second but if you're listening you're
invited to a reception for Time
Traveller's hosted by Stephen Hawking
the party will take place at the
University of Cambridge United Kingdom
on June 28th 2009 no RSVP required and
hey if you have a chance to jump in a
spaceship and enjoy the time-traveling
effects of a black hole do it just make
sure not to fall into that gravitational
monster but that's a story for another
what if
[Music]